peut-on vivre du cyclisme que faut-il
manger le matin avant une course ou
encore avez vous beaucoup voyagé voici
une idée des questions posées aux
anciens cyclistes professionnels sandy
casar et thomas voeckler par les élèves
du collège les molières aux
essarts-le-roi dans la salle des jeunes
fans aux anges c'est super c'est
agréable ça m'a fait découvrir plein de
trucs franchement franchement c'était
génial je pensais pas les rencontres un
jour parce que je les connais quand même
et ça fait plaisir c'était super j'ai
appris plein de choses et ils ont pu
répondre à ces questions que j'avais un
plaisir partagé par les coureurs je
trouve ça très très très sympa parce que
mon yahoo il parlait de du cyclisme
d'autres sports de paris nice mais il ya
aussi parler c'est une coréalisation
avec la vie de tous les jours c'est à
dire que il y à l'entraînement la
persévérance les difficultés parce que
le vélo c'est ça il ya des jours où on
est bien on n'est pas bien c'est
exactement la vie et on a des questions
aussi des collégiens qui sont un peu
différent de d'habitude c'est important
c'est sympa parce que c'est vrai qu'on
est habitué au quotidien aux questions
des journalistes et convient dans les
collèges comme chaque année
on dans les yvelines avec paris nice et
bien il ya des questions qui change
rafraîchissante bien préparé donc c'est
un grand plaisir et de venir répondre
aux jeunes une rencontre organisée par
le département des yvelines et amaury
sport organisation à l'occasion de paris
nice cette année la course du soleil
s'est élancé de mantes-la-ville une
fierté de plus pour sandy casar ma grand
mère habitait à mantes-la-ville ma mère
est aidé mantes-la-ville en plus pour
moi c'était un petit clin d'oeil où j'ai
fait deuxième sur cette course là en
2002 sa fait 20ans sa part de
mantes-la-ville bon voilà c'est départ
du et divine de mon département
d'origine chevaux pour moi c'est
important la 80e édition de paris-nice
s'achèvera le 13 mars prochain